Este vídeo ha sido posible gracias a Surfshark,
más sobre esto en un momento.
Si creéis que la invasión de Rusia a Ucrania
va a ser la única de la década, puede que
estéis en lo cierto…
Pero… para hacer tal pronóstico con garantías
nos exigiría saber cómo demonios se va a
comportar China.
Ya sabéis que este país ya lleva un tiempo
amenazando con invadir Taiwán.
Y, sí, seguramente muchos pensaríais que
tarde o temprano la isla se convertirá en
la nueva Ucrania, pero…
¿Y si os dijéramos que hay quien piensa
que llegado el caso la Ucrania de Asia podría
llegar a ser Vietnam y no Taiwán?
Y, ojo, que no hablamos de meras especulaciones.
Hay argumentos suficientes como para pensar
que el riesgo existe.
N1(Aumenta la tensión entre China, Vietnam
y Filipinas por islas en disputa.
La Vanguardia)
De hecho, China ha llegado a hundir barcos
pesqueros vietnamitas en el Mar de la China
Meridional.
Pero, seamos honestos, esto no es nada nuevo
para Vietnam, al fin y al cabo, ambos países
ya estuvieron en guerra en 1979, justo después
de que terminara la famosa guerra civil en
la que intervino Estados Unidos.
[Pero, un momento, ¿no se supone que ambos
son países con regímenes comunistas?
¿Acaso no les unía el socialismo internacional?)
Pues sí, ambos eran - y supuestamente siguen
siendo - regímenes comunistas férreos, pero,
queridos amigos, amigas cuando se trata de
luchas por el poder…
la ideología pasa a un segundo plano.
El caso es que no puede extrañarnos que Vietnam
esté intentando fortalecerse todo lo posible
para evitar otra posible invasión china.
Y desde luego, ¿qué queréis que os diga?
Su historia nos dice que es el movimiento
más inteligente que puede hacer.
Y, claro, esto es algo que, como veremos,
a Estados Unidos le interesa, y mucho.
Pensadlo bien, Estados Unidos quiere frenar
el expansionismo chino en el mar de la China
Meridional, un objetivo compartido por Vietnam,
un país que podría jugar aquí un papel
crucial.
(Con casi 100 millones de habitantes y un
crecimiento económico impresionante en los
últimos años - poco a poco Vietnam se va
perfilando como otro futuro contrapeso regional
a China.
Otro más.
Ya sabéis, junto a Japón, Corea del Sur,
Singapur, Filipinas, posiblemente la India
y otros tantos países de la zona.
La posición de China no es tan fuerte como
podríamos pensar a simple vista.)
Ahora bien, no podemos olvidar que Vietnam
sigue siendo una dictadura comunista, y hacer
alianzas con regímenes autoritarios puede
conllevar un montón problemas.
No hay más que ver la situación de la OTAN
con Turquía…
Pero de eso hablaremos en otro vídeo.
Por ahora la pregunta es: ¿de verdad puede
occidente fiarse de Vietnam?
¿Hasta qué punto podría llegar a convertirse
en un socio militar fiable para Estados Unidos?
¿Podrían las tensiones entre Vietnam y China
terminar provocando otra guerra?
Hoy vamos a responder a estas preguntas, pero
antes vamos a ver un poco de historia.
(Pero antes, una pregunta: ¿sabes todo lo
que te estás perdiendo por no usar Surfshark?
Lo primero y más importante: la protección
de navegar de forma segura.
Surfshark te protege cifrando tu actividad
en internet de modo que nadie pueda rastrear
ni robar tus datos; Bloquea anuncios y malware
con CleanWeb; y protege tus cuentas de correo
electrónico con Surfshark Alert, avisándote
cuando se filtre tu información personal.
Pero espera porque aún hay más.
Surfshark es la primera VPN comercial con
servidores en más de 100 países distintos,
lo que significa que puedes abrir a golpe
de click un nuevo mundo de contenidos restringidos
según tu ubicación.
Además, con una misma cuenta podrás registrar
TODOS los dispositivos que quieras sin límite:
tu teléfono, tablet, la SmartTV, el portátil.
Y lo mejor de todo: por ser parte de la comunidad
VisualPolitik podrás disfrutar de un 83%
de descuento y 3 meses gratis usando el código
“POLITIK”.
Y dicho esto, ¡continuemos con nuestro video
de hoy!)Pero antes, una pregunta: ¿sabes
todo lo que te estás perdiendo por no usar
Surfshark?
Lo primero y más importante: la protección
de navegar de forma segura.
Surfshark te protege cifrando tu actividad
en internet de modo que nadie pueda rastrear
ni robar tus datos; Bloquea anuncios y malware
con CleanWeb; y protege tus cuentas de correo
electrónico con Surfshark Alert, avisándote
cuando se filtre tu información personal.
Pero espera porque aún hay más.
Surfshark es la primera VPN comercial con
servidores en más de 100 países distintos,
lo que significa que puedes abrir a golpe
de click un nuevo mundo de contenidos restringidos
según tu ubicación.
Además, con una misma cuenta podrás registrar
TODOS los dispositivos que quieras sin límite:
tu teléfono, tablet, la SmartTV, el portátil.
Y lo mejor de todo: por ser parte de la comunidad
VisualPolitik podrás disfrutar de un 83%
de descuento y 3 meses gratis usando el código
“POLITIK”.
Y dicho esto, ¡continuemos con nuestro video
de hoy!
T1(LA ENCRUCIJADA DEL COMUNISMO ASIÁTICO)
Cuando nos fijamos en la historia y en cómo
se organizan China y Vietnam internamente,
vemos que, a primera vista, parecen ser realidades
básicamente paralelas:
Ambos países llevaron a cabo revoluciones
socialistas, ambos establecieron dictaduras
comunistas que aún perduran, y ambos empezaron
a reformar sus economías para abrirse de
par en par al mercado internacional.
Claro que, Vietnam empezó su reforma económica
en 1986 con el Doi Moi, es decir, 8 años
después de que se pusieran en marcha las
reformas económicas de Deng Xiaoping en China.
El caso es que ambos países comenzaron a
promover la propiedad privada en el campo
y, en general, en el resto de la economía.
También potenciaron la inversión extranjera
e intensificaron sus relaciones comerciales
con el mundo.
Gracias a este cambio, al final, cosecharon
un jugoso resultado: tal y como podéis ver,
sus economías comenzaron a despegar.
Tal y como podéis ver, China, que comenzó
sus reformas casi una década antes, se distanció
de Vietnam, sobre todo cuándo se integró
en la Organización Mundial del Comercio a
comienzos del s.XXI.
Pero, no importante, en general, los dos países
han seguido una trayectoria más que notable.
En apenas 30 años Vietnam ha multiplicado
el valor real de su producción por 12.
Claro que China lo hizo casi por 20.
Y es que lo cierto es que hablamos de dos
países con muchas similitudes…
Pero al mismo tiempo también muy diferentes.
En el caso de Vietnam, además de llegar casi
una década más tarde a la oleada de reformas
económica, hay que tener en cuenta que cuando
esta finalmente llega este país acababa de
pasar por dos guerras: una guerra civil en
la que participó Estados Unidos y, más tarde,
una guerra contra China que salió en defensa
del régimen camboyano de uno de los mayores
genocidas de toda la historia, Pol Pot.
En general, podemos decir que Vietnam abrazó
las reformas cuándo era más pobre y tenía,
incluso, más problemas de todo tipo que China.
En parte, esa diferencia explica la brecha
actual.
Claro que hoy en día, las diferencias van
más allá del terreno meramente económico.
N2(China, entre el poder colectivo y el personalismo
de Xi Jinping.
ABC)
Exacto, mientras que en los últimos años
en China el personalismo llevado al extremo
ha vuelto a ganar fuerza con Xi Jinping, en
Vietnam la cosa parece diferente, y prueba
de ello son noticias como esta:
N3(El presidente de Vietnam, Nguyen Xuan Phuc,
dimite en medio de la campaña anticorrupción
del Partido Comunista.
CNN)
Y es que, veréis, en China, desde 1989, el
secretario general del Partido Comunista ha
sido también el presidente del país.
En Vietnam, en cambio, hoy por hoy esto parece
impensable.
De hecho, la dictadura comunista vietnamita
descansa en 4 pilares: la secretaría general,
el primer ministro, el presidente y el Líder
de la Asamblea Nacional.
Desde la muerte de Ho Chi Minh ni más ni
menos que en 1969, cada uno de estos cargos
ha recaído en personas diferentes que funcionan,
en cierta forma, como contrapesos unos de
otros.
Y de hecho, la Asamblea Nacional de Vietnam,
que a ver, evidentemente, no es democrática,
al menos sí que algo de actividad real.
Incluso puede vetar resoluciones y, llegado
el caso, proponer mociones de confianza contra
el primer ministro.
Hasta ahora esto ha permitido oxigenar algo
más el aparato oficial.
Sí, en China existía la alternancia del
líder y de las élites políticas…
Pero con Xi Jinping ha desaparecido.
Y, ¿qué significa todo esto?
Pues básicamente que en Vietnam nadie pueda
cambiar el rumbo así por las buenas, como,
en cambio, si puede hacer Xi Jinping en China.
Y generalmente también conlleva menos restricciones
para la población.
Por ejemplo, mientras en China Facebook y
YouTube están totalmente bloqueados, en Vietnam
hay acceso libre, aunque con algunas restricciones
incluso a videos que critican al Partido Comunista.
Pero aparte del proyecto político interno,
donde encontramos las mayores diferencias
entre ambos países es sobre todo en su política
en el mar de la China Meridional, aunque bueno,
también tienen una importante similitud:
ambos países reclaman los mismos territorios.
Y eso implica que las tensiones podrían dispararse
y repetir de nuevo la historia.
No olvidéis que ambos países estuvieron
en guerra en 1979.
La pregunta es: ¿Cómo espera Vietnam evitar
que la tensión se dispare con su vecino norte?
Pues bien, veámoslo.
T2(DESDE RUSIA, CON AMOR)
Es inevitable, cada vez que nos hablan de
Vietnam, inmediatamente pensamos en aquella
guerra de la que se han hecho docenas de películas
y en la que Estados Unidos se involucró apoyando
al sur del país con decenas y decenas de
miles de soldados.
Para que os hagáis una idea, en 1968 la potencia
Norteamérica llegó a tener desplegados casi
600 mil soldados en este país.
En total, Estados Unidos participó en esta
guerra durante 12 larguísimos años.
Pero seguro que lo que muchos no sabíais
es que justo después de que acabara esta
guerra, China invadió Vietnam en 1979.
Y aparentemente hoy las cosas no serían muy
diferentes: la exposición de Vietnam a China
sigue siendo enorme.
Fijaos en este mapa: Si prestáis atención,
geográficamente Vietnam está totalmente
a merced de China, ya sea por su frontera
en el norte - que fue por donde los chinos
les invadieron en el 79 - como por la costa
donde además de estar prácticamente rodean
se enfrentan a la mayor armada por número
de barcos de todo el mundo.
Y no olvidemos que por el sur está la Camboya,
es aliada de China y luego está Laos que
podría cambiar de bando a conveniencia del
mejor postor.
Y claro, entonces, ante tal panorama, la pregunta
es, ¿realmente puede Vietnam tener un discurso
claramente independiente?
Pues básicamente este es el motivo que explica
por qué en los últimos años, Vietnam se
ha ido acercándose cada vez más y más a
países como Japón o la India, tanto militar
como comercialmente,
Pero, queridos amigos, seamos honestos, la
amistad entre estos países es más bien superficial.
Si de verdad queremos encontrar al que siempre
ha sido el mejor amigo de Vietnam, nos tenemos
que ir al país que ha copado todas las portadas
de la prensa internacional este último año.
Exacto, estamos hablando de Rusia.
(Ya desde la época Ho Chi Minh la influencia
de Moscú en el país ha sido infinitamente
mayor que la de Pekín.
En cierto modo, esto tiene mucho que ver con
que las raíces del pensamiento comunista
de Vietnam procedan directamente del marxismo-leninismo
soviético.
Por lo tanto, no es de extrañar que sus lazos
con la Unión Soviética fuesen tan estrechos.
Lo que explica, en buena medida, porque Estados
Unidos se tomó tan en serio esta guerra.
Un conflicto en el que las tropas norvietnamitas
contaron con el apoyo y la asistencia de la
Unión Soviética.
Que es exactamente lo que volvió a suceder
cuándo en 1979 China invadió el país como
represalia por el hecho que Vietnam hubiera
atacado y derrocado al sangriento régimen
de los jemeres rojos en Camboya.)
Ya fuera durante la invasión estadounidense
o la china, la Unión Soviética, el socio
más fiel de la Vietnam comunista, ayudó
al país enviando un montón de armas como,
por ejemplo, misiles antiaéreos, ametralladoras
ligeras o el famoso fusil de asalto AK-47.
El caso es que si sus relaciones ya eran de
por sí estrecha, a partir de ese momento
la amistad fue mucho más sólida.
De hecho, hoy en día Rusia sigue siendo mayor
socio en términos de armas del ejército
vietnamita.
Y de hecho, Rusia tiene, incluso, acceso preferente
a una de las bases vietnamitas más importantes,
la de la bahía de Cam Ranh.
Pero, ojo, porque ahí no termina todo.
Vietnam no confió en la Unión Soviética
y en la Rusia actual solo para conseguir armas.
La cooperación económica también ha sido
clave durante este tiempo.
¿Queréis un ejemplo reciente?
Pues fijaos, en los últimos años Vietnam
ha intentado extraer petróleo en el mar de
China Meridional, de la mano de un montón
de multinacionales.
Sin ir más lejos Repsol.
Sin embargo, hablamos de zonas en disputa,
y, claro, el petróleo iba a salir más rápido
y con menos problemas si se metía alguna
empresa estatal rusa de por medio que lograra
intimidar un poquito, tan solo un poquito
a China.
[Sobre todo por el miedo a perjudicar sus
relaciones con Moscú.
O mejor dicho, el empeño del Xi Jinping de
mantener esas relaciones.]
Y, como no, la primera en abalanzarse sobre
esta oportunidad fue Rosneft, aunque luego
vendiera toda su participación a Zarubezhneft,
otra empresa energética del Estado ruso.
Y, os hago una pregunta, ¿cómo creéis que
Vietnam le devuelve los favores a Rusia?
Pues con noticias como esta:
N4(Vietnam y Tailandia se abstienen en la
votación de la ONU para condenar la anexión
rusa de Ucrania.
RFA)
Exacto, Vietnam es uno de los pocos países
del mundo que evitan condenar la invasión
rusa de Ucrania.
Y, tiene sentido, si no llega a ser por el
apoyo constante de la Unión Soviética antes
y de la actual Rusia actualmente, posiblemente
Vietnam no sería lo que es hoy.
Pero evidentemente, si llegado el caso, China
quisiera dar un golpe de mano y castigar o
cambiar al gobierno vietnamita o, incluso,
invadir este país para convertirlo en un
estado satélite, los rusos no serían una
ayuda.
Hoy por hoy, dadas las nuevas capacidades
del ejército chino y las debilidades manifiesta
de Rusia, sería muy difícil por no decir
imposible que Moscú pudiera serles de alguna
ayuda.
Y no lo dudéis.
En Hanói tienen esto claro meridiano: Tienen
a su lado a una de las mayores potencias del
mundo, una potencia cada vez más expansionista
y con la que no se llevan particularmente
bien.
Y, en cualquier caso, no quieren ser un país
satélite.
(Para evitar un posible choque, en los últimos
años en Hanói han intentado mejorar sus
relaciones con Pekín.
Y es que no se trata solo de una cuestión
territorial o militar.
Para situarnos, casi el 40% de todas las importaciones
vietnamitas proviene de China, lo que incluye,
circuitos integrados, teléfonos, semiconductores…
En definitiva, prácticamente todo lo que
el país necesita para desarrollarse tecnológicamente.)
Esto explica, por ejemplo, porque ambos países
hayan realizado en lo que llevamos de siglos
decenas de ejercicios de cooperación militar.
Y sobre todo explica la política exterior
basada en la filosofía de lo 3 noes:
No permitir bases militares extranjeras en
Vietnam, no formar parte de alianzas militares,
y no apoyar a un país en su lucha contra
otro.
Todo para enfadar a China.
Pero, ¿y si esta reducción hubiera sido
un error?
Pese a todo, las tensiones en el mar de la
China Meridional con China llevan aumentando
en esta última década y la situación en
la zona ya no es para tomársela a la ligera.
Atentos:
T3(DEJANDO EL PASADO ATRÁS)
Ya os hemos contado antes cómo Vietnam se
embarcó en una serie de reformas económicas
promercado a partir del año 86.
Es algo de lo que os hablamos con todo detalle
en un pasado vídeo aquí en VisualPolitik.
Pero para los que no lo hayáis visto o, simplemente,
no os acordéis:
Al principio estas reformas se limitaron al
sector agrícola, para después saltar al
resto de áreas.
Entre las que destacó la búsqueda a toda
costa de la industrialización del país.
Lo que para tener éxito exigía recibir y
cortejar a los inversores del resto del mundo.
Y, amigos, se lo tomaron muy en serio.
Hoy en día no es extraño que veamos cómo
marcas de todo el mundo producen ya en Vietnam.
Hablamos de compañías como Samsung, H&M,
Adidas, Nike o Foxconn.
De hecho, el mayor cliente de Vietnam por
mucha diferencia es Estados Unidos.
Lo que no resulta nada sorprendente.
Las relaciones con la superpotencia norteamericana
han mejorado mucho en los últimos años.
Atrás quedaron los tiempos de la guerra y
la desconfianza.
En 1995 los dos países restablecieron formalmente
sus relaciones diplomáticas, en el año 2000
firmaron un Acuerdo Comercial Bilateral, en
2007 Vietnam se unió a la Organización Mundial
del Comercio con el apoyo explícito de Washington
y en 2016 Estados Unidos levantó completamente
el embargo de armas a Vietnam, lo que permitió
una mayor cooperación en temas de seguridad
y defensa.
Incluso todos pudimos ver imágenes como estas:
Desde entonces, los dos países han desarrollado
numerosos ejercicios militares conjuntos y
habitualmente colaboran en la seguridad marítima
y la libertad de navegación en la región
del Indo-Pacífico.
Ahora bien, si os hemos dicho que Vietnam
ha intentado llevarse lo mejor posible con
China, ¿qué explica que repente quiera crear
un vínculo con su histórico archienemigo
y hoy por hoy gran adversario de China?
Pues, más allá de cuestiones económicas,
lo cierto es que en Hanoi no se fian un pelo
de Pekín.
De hecho, en 2014 la tensión entre ambos
países llegó a un nivel extremo cuando China
llevó una plataforma petrolera semisumergible
para explorar y explotar petróleo en territorio
marítimo vietnamita.
Y no solo eso, la construcción de islas artificiales
en torno a los archipiélagos Spratly y Paracel
que la propia Vietnam reclama como propias,
han hecho que la tensión no deje de crecer
en la región, especialmente por el hardware
militar que China está instalando en estas
islas.
Por eso en Hanói parecen entender ahora que
ni Moscú ni Pekín son sus mejores garantías,
sino que estas pueden proceder de Estados
Unidos y su órbita de países aliados en
la zona.
Por supuesto, en Washington han visto esta
jugada como todo un golpe de fortuna: algo
así como otro potencial socio a sumar a su
ya larga lista de países enfadados o recelososo
de China.
Y en cierto modo eso es lo que explica noticias
como estas:
(29 de marzo de 2018: Estados Unidos transfiere
a Vietnam seis patrulleras tipo Shark.
Embajada de Estados Unidos en Vietnam)
N7(17 dic 2022: Análisis: Vietnam cambia
de marcha en el comercio de armas y afloja
lazos con Rusia.
Reuters)
Ahora, en vez de estar comprando armas rusas,
son las armas estadounidenses, surcoreanas
e israelís las que están inundando Vietnam.
Ahora bien, ¿significa esto que Vietnam va
a cambiar su filosofía de los “3 noes”
y se va a echar por completo a los brazos
del tío Sam?
Pues, definitivamente, no.
Vietnam es un extraño caso de país que hoy
parece querer llevarse bien con Pekín, Moscú
y Washington al mismo tiempo
Y no nos engañemos: Vietnam sigue siendo
una dictadura comunista.
Los valores políticos y democráticos occidentales
no forman parte del Partido Comunista de,
y esto hace que la confianza que Estados Unidos
pueda tener en Vietnam no sea demasiada.
Desde luego, es prácticamente imposible imaginar
una Vietnam interviniendo junto a Estados
Unidos en Taiwán para evitar un ataque de
China.
Pero ahora la pregunta es para vosotros, de
ser Vietnam, ¿Por quien tomarías partido?
¿Por Moscú, Pekín o Washington?
Déjanos tus respuestas en los comentarios
y abramos debate.
Si este vídeo os ha resultado interesante
no olvidéis darle a like y suscribiros a
VisualPolitik si es que aún no lo habéis
hecho.
¡Ah!
Y recordad, con el código “POLITIK” acabado
en “K” podréis disfrutar de un 83% de
descuento y 3 meses gratis de Surfshark.
El link, como siempre, en la descripción.
Muchas gracias por estar ahí,
Un saludo y hasta la próxima.